[Music]
oh goodness so at it will go on focus on
these after the convergence tons of all
stop today just the taste as you'd rival
team solomid and cloud9 go at and
whenever these two teams meet it's
obviously always a hotly contested game
but while the rivalry may be intent the
respect for one another is really GSM
trying to go all-in on hind so there is
a kidney how videos flying up throwing a
wild turtle so deep he's practically in
the endzone by himself
hi take them down this could be it
sneaky takes on Reginald three have
fallen for Team solomid Oh force goes
down and dyrus is heading for the
fountain but so is cloud nine that one a
demolishing of TSM T menials also fight
all that was due so coming out of that
this is gonna be a hectic fight they are
powered up team soul man is going big
lemonnation able to come up so it
static says lemonnation of a run here
kill time he's only giving us euro one
person but t f7l has a crowd behind him
he'd like it tonight with their eyes on
the Nexus sir eyes on the summer split
completely undefeated appearing 25 and 3
over 90% win rate loud sigh sobbing how
undoubtedly one of the best teams we
have seen in North America we did finish
very flat split but that really doesn't
mean anything coming into this next
split everyone starts off same place
it's definitely more competition it'll
be hard to defend our spot welcome back
to the opening day of the 2014 North
American spring split we start off our
super week with a highly anticipated
matchup defending champ cloud 9 vs fan
favorite team solomid give him at abusin
so they're gonna be a lot stronger now
we've been screaming call 911
where is the Greg fellow Wallace pesto
may not even get that for himself the
explosive cap is still up Pearson
finally uses it but it's incomplete
defense that's when he was dying the
id-1 looking to go down next he tries to
put absolute zero in a great spot London
nation with a nice fling onto that but
actually the kill goes to balls and
they're able to get another kill on to
die receiving only wildturtle to run for
his life they are just absolutely taking
everything they can away from TSM and
the wind
17:09 your first came to the north
barrack now yes
while diet has been legendary against
Team solomid with seven straight wins
Kobe will stands before four during the
summer split and three during the finals
of the playoff also the spring split
champions or TSM in the summer split
champions where cloud miles that has an
amazing 25 and free run best record in
the history of the LCS regular season
CSM is doing they haven't had much time
to farm when dealing with the sparing by
Washington agents there it is again out
the meteos forced to use the zhonya's
and he's not on crowstorm toast out
instantly a huge amount of dps is Oliver
Li being what if video gets caught out
as entities fight fog I will talk with
his a pic that does not seem to be
working in their favor the crowd still
very much so much chance but they're
going into for gonna have the time
that's the third time Turtles been
really close to gets himself out with a
flash the Quicksilver as well is there
to assist they're trying to go in on
this but that's not much damage coming
from medius it's like the fight really
wasn't engaged but it is accessible
taking down elimination and he is again
in the four other fighters around he
both is the one getting hit up they're
going to take him down and hit right in
the name think he goes down next video
is on the board as well lasagnas goes
but he goes out I think this is the game
riff that was another clean fight for
TSM it's an amazing game team solomid
going to take sole possession of birth
birth place over cloud nine gives them
their second loss of the season and
they're going to look to be seven and
one now in the spring split
[Applause]
and I really think we have a an
expanding rivalry between TSM cause I
know it's the first time GSM is kind of
fought back in there's an old saying
that like a series doesn't start until
both teams win a game and now GSM is
started the robbery people finally been
able to stuff our last ball Center comes
to join in limitation to flash engage
the black shield is on a massive Sun
comes through a special low on health
heal themself up auto chases down sneaky
look at the kill wild turtle goes down
to media the special goes down as well
the repel in the air a340 on disengage
and meteos and high are still unkilled
in the series despite taking down for
members of TSM Wow nine go to the series
3-0 they're going to take down the Nexus
and they are the North American champion
they're over all killed that the
mysterious is ridiculous
we are in the game 5 of 9 vs team
solomid with the cooldown discipline of
these teams is remarkable still though
Yasuo still believed until now the shock
wave also didn't twist in advance
throws down the multi Maelstrom and it
looks like they're going to mitigate
enough damage took care of this fight
apart in the start it's going to be wild
turtle now in the eye more down for Team
solomid dyrus is forced to run for the
brush and cloud 9 head for Barrett needs
to reassess the fight
Wolcott hit up the glacial fissure on
the backside they bottleneck into this
fight in our : Primrose hoggle did
Christ get his oak sit down laughs glass
breath has already been used coming up
with Brutus Walker so turns on the
circle
for the playoffs eternal 40-minute game
60,000 goals apiece on each side and
video sizes damndest to stop it after
all the tensions yes m5 the fight and
wild turtle goes wild right there on
that line 2014 North American champion
[Applause]
now today's final latest and growing
rivalry between Team solomid and cloud
nine
it's one of the fans enjoy watching and
once again it will dictate who's the top
dog and getting out there the only teams
that have won in North America t9 and
gives them sitting in the trophy has
always been just on this legacy it's
currently tip them and I really don't
want them to keep it you know coming
into this can they get her on the
choppers without hitting right just
Laurie doesn't really get in there man
says 1e ultimate TSM can make it through
this they got it the cloud nine is
locking them down here soon on the
outside he gets walked in with the
position reverser how he is still alive
in this one they are doing everything
they can but cloud 9 closes the door on
that fights and game for between cloud 9
and team solomid the theory stands at
two to one in favorite team solomid now
they just need one more win to defend
their championship title just in the
last second so what we want to be r sit
in hi the fight goes down but heís alive
and beers too dies to the turret turtle
now is the focus % charge into anchor
toss they lock him down with the passive
but he is hopping around way too much on
Calissa
startle a double Charlotte Ursula Quadra
could he be coming up with a Penta PI
stays on the fountains of quadrakill
once again to come up with Team solomid
pivotal win on the North American spring
Flint
teams
by the 2015 North American League of
Legends Championship Series spring flick
champions
[Music]
[Applause]
showing up huge throughout this
fancified series again one of their
biggest rival club I just like to thank
all of our fans all of our sponsors all
my teammates all the generic stuff I say
every every single month and year every
time we win loot is coming out as well
they're going to wipeout team solvate
here
spirits a very low can only do a few
things from the outside and they might
cast as last ability here his snap comes
from the explosive cast in a slam of the
valley coming in from me do a triple
kill for sneaky balls chasing out dyrus
and potentially an inside-the-park a
sears dyers won't be able to do mine's
the pink cloud 9 pick up the first win
of the summer split over king solomon
against the defending champs right there
two down a hundred-plus yes in the mid
lane five dragons to zero
yo cloud 9 wins the teamfights down the
stretch the rumble altima the full chain
to connect he gets the front end burst
out of the Lavoie combo Pearson picks
one up and that lights up views for the
fight that could be the final one here
against cloud 9 28 minutes into the base
onto the inhibitor not many minions
behind them but once they will get our
parents up so they may have some time
with his turret Oakland to get a sonic
wave and a follow up on the double if
they're going to lose the inhibitor here
without even pressuring back and that
may be it it's audio damage is
absolutely used for fall to the rest of
the team they are spreading peaceful
amid right now Justin goes to the back
just so we can make sure he has priority
target that's going to be a sanyas
retention the kill
going over onto beer sin and now they're
going to finalize a few more pots are
taking his last breath as cloud 9
finally defensive 8 TSM is now on the
back end of these fights completely
scared of cloud 9 composition and c9 is
going to use this their advantage I was
holding their doubles didn't get to Auto
Attack he didn't get to stand still he
was all the edge they're in double if
he's getting too close
as soon as Darren Yost are winning that
was it cloud9 have how's our breath 46
minutes waiting for the right fights
waiting to scale waiting for the right
items and they have found it now they
will be grabbing a share of second place
somewhere you want to be coming into the
end of this place 22:26
46 minutes and cloud 9 takes down TSM
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
North American summer finals we're
coming to you live from the Air Canada
Centre in Toronto Ontario cloud 9 sgsn
who battled today for the title of the
North American champion announcement of
at Taman hopeful when I play the ball is
a pillock exile from food in my eyes w
pop the gray helping out goblins in
danger he's going to go down for 59 to
be throughout play in the bot lane in
already opening up his smoothie slow
down have a nice body slam you look for
ginger buddy for the captain's not put
him into the team so far so good
forecast if he applies that stays alive
talk to the snipe and the fight is then
seek with hurricane looking for damage
there's a black market they're gonna go
for buy up front that will be CSM TV my
swords going down they find one so
looking for two Bjork's is good up there
to force e97 up to on the scoreboard
right now looking towards Barry and
actually ESM's going for the fight right
now teleport behind me herpes okay take
one socket to see little probably time I
without doing much board let's go to the
side haaaaa there is a look for incense
and he's got out of the backline and
it's going to be the attest appeal here
comes beer come in as well
for the carry seven cents of the Jensen
here for the top above his rod think
about diseases by the quick Sonja's
bobbin double 6s bilbies - already 14
subjects running down he will bleed out
and that's not a good thing 40s that
monsters impacted therapy when a killing
spree because they catch insensible live
and knock up here and it's going to be
another gift bags up and now it's double
live alone running back into his face he
gets some support back from fester and
when it's doable they probably do take
abscess since then overall the three
four twos flight they want this there
the battle on top of the inhibitor to be
is going to lose this life as they go
hey Game one go six love nine impact of
the frontline your community go for the
knock and pay my question yes they do
FiOS process down booth is going to
trade applies as well though former
before no supports alive no garden asel
for videos whereas DSM still have to and
we're all we resolve with some couple
now can they have the follow-up damage a
couple cells come in they've got
derrickson and they set up down to
sixteen hundred damage fringes can okay
no Volvo meteos another knock
constraints is lifeless down below it
should be a Stefano all guilty
saf3 if that goes down and a sturdy fo
double lift bar throughout the fight
gang
but then he had them find another fight
at Baron c9 did not want to give up that
baron in TSM was so strong with the
elder Drake never to take that fight all
the way to the championship they didn't
give up the baron but they're going to
give up a championship as the Nexus it's
surely going to fall and here we go the
ceremonial taking of the Nexus turret
nothing to stand in their way as CSM
cements themselves as the most dominant
organization North American League of
Legends and win their fourth North
American Championship your 2016 summer
split champion
[Applause]
welcome ladies and gentlemen today one
of the 2017 North American League
Championship Series last year's summer
final defending champion TSM up against
cloud nine these two teams obviously
incredible and these two teams are part
of the reason everyone is so hype to get
to sleep off the ground here Bahai long
time
Sonia's out of your sins so to stop with
the shark and that's the first set down
contract missus wants a bit more wild
girl running for dear life baptism
through another trade in a three for one
so far about on a complete control how
nine are going to take these first gain
way to the 2017 North American LCS
season nothing to land back in the
predator books organ solo last time they
can't quite reach it so the fight
continues go to nasal block the
redemption you're going to be nice 59
and it's a one kill pickup so far as
contracts has fallen to the hostler up
next and it looks like 15 regions life
as well to take eternal discreetly
running away again
joining angels down into the abyss
the paper foil from sticking along
everybody
it's gonna be in fact the last one to
fall you will go down a double and the
qo is all but secured just want a little
bit match the previous and a little bit
just a bit more one side of the game one
here cloud9
this side off the backs of contract with
the insane early game on lease in truths
Bureau over DSM Brian is owned an Alfa
gentlemen to dive in for he's under
title damages big defense on the finish
everything is 79 it might they've
totally exhausted does though don't flex
out of them they have to get out the
raid I think I've handed up and there
goes go sees I walk in and say oh my
goodness that's it still at it no go on
focus on these after the conversion that
was horrible for DSN DS BSC so I fell
after the burn I'm not going to be a
kill CSM take solvent for end rooms get
a cup of the King for the NA LCS a will
handy cloud 9 their first loss of the
spring
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button